- [Student] Something your
teachers don't want you
to know with online school.
If you really don't
feel like typing notes,
just press your FN key twice.
This will literally type
what your teacher is saying
and you won't have to write notes.
(playful music)
Instead of Google, use Google Scholar.
Because once you do this,
you can literally press
these buttons and it
cites everything for you.
And they have more precise articles.
They're called email trackers.
So I can tell when my
teachers have opened my emails
and how many times and if they haven't.
So when they say this, you'll know.
You'll just know.
Go to the Google app and
press the camera icon.
They have a homework section underneath.
Scan your homework with this.
And it'll literally tell
you the right answers.
It's called the YouTube Transcript.
This basically shows you
everything that's being said
in the video.
And you can press Control + F.
if you're ever given a worksheet,
just press the keywords
that you're looking for
and they'll come up here
and you won't have to
watch the whole video.
(playful music)
A lot of teachers upload
their lessons from Zoom
to the cloud converter, and
it gives us audio transcript.
Hypothetically, you could
copy-paste all of the transcripts,
put them into one document,
and then when you're
doing open-book exams,
you press Control + F and search keywords.
So you'd practically get
every question right.
You don't have to read your article guide.
Instead, use Podcastle
free Chrome extension.
Convert your articles into podcasts.
Make a shared document like a Google doc.
That's a study guide
for midterm and finals.
Now share this document
with everyone in your class.
And get everyone to add stuff in.
Now you can learn off
other people's things
and they can learn off yours.
If you forget to hand in an assignment
and you're past the time,
go to your Time and Date
settings and change them.
The portal will reset and
you actually won't be late.
Instead of Google, use Google Scholar.
This will help you find
more reliable sources
and it's easier to navigate,
especially for research projects.
If you don't know how
to start off your essay,
do it with a quote.
And then also explain the quote.
This adds more words to your essay
and it acts as a hook
to engage your reader.
If you're allowed to pick
your own essay topic,
choose one that makes you angry.
This will allow you to rant
on and on about your topic
and you won't be worried about being short
of the word limit.
Once you're done writing your essay,
copy and paste it onto
a word-to-text reader.
This will read out your essay,
and will allow you to catch your mistakes.
When you're doing research
on your essay topic,
put PPT after your research topic.
This will bring up PowerPoints
which have important
and concise information
about your research topic
that will help you
understand what to include
in your essay and what not to.
Do you suck at math?
Well, here's a tool to help you with that.
It's called Mathchops.
It's a math prep tool that has a database
of the most common SAT and ACT questions.
They use an algorithm to
check what you're bad at
and help you with that
in the form of games
which is so fun.